foreign
let me just say something nice about the
Marvel Universe before we get all up in
it okay of all the communities of
superheroes that exist okay the Marvel
Superheroes more than not derived from
some kind of science or scientific
principle if not the people themselves
you look at Spider-Man you know he was
in his science class and he gets bitten
by a radioactive spider right Dr Banner
is a medical doctor he becomes the Hulk
Iron Man is Iron Man he's a total genius
unlike Batman not to pit DC against
Marvel but Batman is smart but he's not
the one inventing this stuff that makes
him powerful exactly he's got his
company he's got his whole company right
that is that's producing military
contracting company right with engineers
in the in The Silo doing their work Iron
Man is doing all his own work so I
applaud Marvel I don't know where the
science is in Hawkeye okay he's got no
powers
and I love watching Black Widow who
doesn't love some good martial arts
right but we don't have to talk about
the science of that because yeah and
they don't have powers they don't have
power they're just super very good shots
yes both of them both of them they'd be
great for like maybe the biathlon
America once again brings home at least
I am Black Widow
familiar with go ahead the Periodic
Table of fictional elements oh well it's
online go check it out yes it's all
there I know so think killium is there
thin Killian think killium that's an
element on the original I Dream of Genie
they needed an Ingot of think helium
there is the stuff that was in the the
absent-minded Professor Flubber Flubber
flubber's on the periodic table and it's
full they got a full periodic table so I
love it oh they also have unotanium from
um uh avatar from Avatar Avatar so all
these elements are there so people have
thought about how one might organize
them I can tell you this one of the
remarkable things about this universe
and the periodic table of elements in
particular is that from element to
element the properties can be so
different from one another that it is
not completely crazy that you just have
an element that has all the properties
of vibranium you know you can take a
cubic inch of gold okay and Hammer it so
thin that you could like Guild an entire
football field with it so gold is the
most malleable element right and that's
why you Guild things with gold right
yeah okay because you don't take much of
it it looks like you have a lot I mean
you can make it so thin that you can
actually brush it onto surfaces and gold
leafing yes you get gold leaf okay so if
you look at the diversity of properties
of elements on the periodic table not
only that the diversity of molecules you
can make with the elements wow here we
have sodium which is a metal soft enough
that you can cut with a knife and it's
poisonous and it'll explode if you put
it in contact with water add chlorine to
it a deadly gas and you have table salt
okay I have oxygen promotes combustion
then I have hydrogen and explosive gas
put them together you make water that
puts out fire right so this diversity of
properties that tells you that vibranium
is one of the most inventive realistic
things you can think of on there it's
got all these properties that no nothing
else has right that's true with anything
else that has properties that nothing
else has
I've got a friend and colleague of mine
from the American Museum of Natural
History Ray win Grant Ray welcome to
start talking hi thanks for having me I
think this is your first time right very
first time not the last so this is you
are a large carniv large carnivore
ecologist
I don't even know what that is wow I I
kind of dig that though I'm not sure
what it is either but I like it you know
but more broadly youth care about the
environment and the intersection of life
and food chain and this sort of thing
and so we've got some questions so what
would happen to the ecosystem if half of
all life was suddenly disappear because
the bad guy on The Avengers end game
snap well in the previous movie he
snatched his fingers and half of all
life goes away and in his warped sense
of justice he's trying to help the other
half survive so that there's sufficient
resources for them now they didn't make
it clear whether they killed all half of
all plant life as well right yeah he
just plant life is also alive
if his reasoning is that he wants to
increase resources then you wouldn't
want to kill half of our plant life
because that's a resource right for the
for the animals for the animal so but
he's also killing half the animals they
didn't make that clear and I don't know
if what they did in the comic book but
let me just ask you if you take half of
any animal species that's in equilibrium
with its environment let's start with an
equilibrium case it's an equilibrium you
take away half of them what happens
that's a good question yeah just like
that yeah yeah we're in perfect balance
and then you just cut that balance in
half right what happens sure a lot of
things happen and I just want to be
clear this is just the animal species
right not plants let's assume that they
didn't cut the plants yeah let's leave
the plants alone makes a big difference
yeah so so it's actually a um you know a
phenomenon that might be potentially
very helpful to the planet because
definitely said that's what he said
that's what Thanos said well the movie
is fairly accurate and what would happen
in is that everything would be cut in
half so we would see a tremendous loss
you know people would be traumatized
there would be a lot of other kind of
large brained animals that would be
traumatized right like the whales and
the elephants and the gorillas that
we've noticed can exhibit emotions
similar to people and also grieve they
grieve death as elephants grieve death
so do gorillas uh and other Apes but go
ahead right right we've even seen them
shed tears and cry in sad situations so
there would be Trump but in general
what's gonna happen is a whole lot of
reproduction and especially with extra
space which means less competition for
resources we might actually see a huge
spike in some populations of animal
species so if you think about if you
have a small population of deer or some
kind of herbivore and a huge Meadow full
of plant food for them to graze in
they're gonna get bigger and fatter and
in the ecological world that means more
fit so we'll see a huge spike in
populations maybe even beyond what
ecologists call a carrying capacity
carrying capacity is a term that we hear
right now a lot when we talk about the
human population this will be the
maximum number of people you would sing
that's what you're saying maximum number
for for the resource load for the
availability of resources the maximum
number to stay in that equilibrium so
what often happens is we'll see a
population actually Spike and overshoot
carrying capacity and then we'll see
another kind of mass death event and
it'll get back into equilibrium so it
would actually technically be kind of an
ecologist's dream to see this happen
especially in theory because it would be
able to test out a lot of our theories
so it would overshoot it would overshoot
yeah different species and different
populations of organisms would overshoot
at different times so like I'm saying
like a deer population herbivores would
probably get there quicker than like
whales or Elephants or people even
rabbits would get there first
exactly you can bet on that so it seems
to me that Captain Marvel yes is
supremely powerful on a level that
should preclude the need for any other
Avenger well yeah why do I need someone
who shoots bows and arrows when I have
Captain Marvel why do I need vibranium
if I have Captain Marvel why do I need
Iron Man who can fly with jets when she
can move through the vacuum of space why
walk out of space suit without a
spacesuit yeah why do I need a Hulk who
smashes things when Captain why do I
need any other Avenger other than
Captain Marvel plus She Glows yes what
else do you need you don't need anything
now here I have issues that's your
personality by the way that glow I'm
just saying so now if you want her to
move through space you can imagine that
she Quantum teleports all right okay I
don't know if you knew this but if you
put water in a glass it can't get out
because the glass has walls right so the
walls are boundaries between the
location of the water and the table
right does it make sense that if the
walls were not there the water would
then settle down and spill all over the
table that's obvious of course so what
that means is the water has a lower
energy state it could occupy but the
walls are preventing it okay because if
you move the walls the water won't stay
there it goes on its own right it's
called a lower energy State okay oh by
the way the table is higher than the
ground if you put a crack in the table
it'll go through the table and hit the
ground right it prefers to be even on
the ground right then it does to be on
the top of the table that it did to be
in your water glass okay Quantum
mechanically you can trap a particle
with the walls of a glass it's a it's
it's a energy well okay okay you can
trap it there well sorry let's look at
uh just the water or a marble stuck in a
little skateboard park and the marble
can roll up and down back and forth back
and forth there it is right it's not
leaving okay if you wanted to leave push
it with fast enough energy so it goes
over the top and then it goes down to
ground level right but you have to give
it energy to get all over that barrier
right to then escape and now it escapes
okay watch it turns out because
particles can also be waves the particle
that's trapped in the well is also a
wave that exists not only everywhere in
the well parts of that wave exist
outside the well so the particle has a
chance a small chance of existing
outside of the well a very high chance
of existing in the world so most of the
times you look at the particles inside
the well every now and then the disc is
outside correct to watch it Escape it
escapes instantly it breaks through the
barrier and no matter the width of that
battery barrier it goes from one side of
the barrier to the other in zero time
right so if she has control over the
quantum Continuum she can then base it's
called tunneling she could tunnel
through any space barrier and be
wherever she wants in the universe
instantaneously so she would be in
effect entangled with the entire
universe very clever yes that would be a
way to have her move through space in
the way that she does wow she she would
be Quantum entangled with every
so that she could then materialize
herself wherever she needs to be wow
having tunneled there through these
barriers correct that's pretty wild
right that's but she still can't move a
damn glove into a minivan
what was the whole Mobius strip thing so
remember Tony he figures out the quantum
key to time travel by asking Jarvis for
a Mobius strip and then he actually
calculates something used in the movie
you stripped and I don't know from there
I'm like okay yeah I don't know if there
was any real science in there after that
so it's called gobbledygook
special kind of movie science right so
there is such a thing as a Mobius strip
okay and a Mobius strip is a fascinating
thing it's a fascinating thing if you
want to make one cut a ribbon to a long
thin strip a ribbon of any length
doesn't matter okay okay maybe make one
a foot long just for a second it may be
two inches wide okay and then you could
tape the ends together to make a loop
all right okay not the sides together
there make a long cylinder right so just
tape the two short ends that would make
a loop right okay that's nothing odd
about a loop no there's an inside of the
loop and the outside you can paint the
inside if you wanted okay and paint the
outside right okay instead this time
instead of connecting them that way give
one of those edges a turn Okay Okay 180
degrees a twist all right then tape them
together so now what you have is kind of
an s-shaped like almost like figure
eight that turns in and out on itself it
is so it goes way more and it goes out
it is way more profound than that okay
okay you ready go ahead that thing has
only one side you could draw a line
along the length of it as you pull the
ribbon through and without Ever Lifting
your pencil off the page without ever
crossing the edge of the page you will
land back where you started and you
would have put a line on all surfaces of
it
it is it is a ribbon that has only one
side
[Music]
and if you cut along that line if you
cut it in half along the line you just
drew
you make a single Loop twice as big you
don't cut it into two parts okay so oh
okay wait wait so so it just becomes
wait a minute
maybe you're feeling pretty visible
visual dude no so I'm saying because
what's happening is the twist now as you
cut as it opens up it just becomes a
circle a bigger Circle okay that's what
it is it's a big circle okay so now the
point is so you've thrown a Mobius strip
which is cool and has a dimensionality
interest to it okay okay but then you
put a time travel spin on it right all
right so if your path through time is on
a Mobius strip you can come back to
where you were but you're not exactly
where you were you're on the other side
of that space right but even though it
only has one side it only has one side
see that's it look at that oh I see what
they did there all right so so if you
had to create mumbo jumbo gobbledygook
Mobius remove the way to go crazy hope
your strip we'll get that for you Chuck
we have hardly any time left I'm doing a
lightning round let's do it what is the
biggest scientific inaccuracy in the
movie in your estimation on all the
spaceships they know made no reference
of any gravity generator and they all
should have been weightless on their
spaceship or have magnets floating
through space yeah but they didn't show
that right we're giving a shout out to
it right nobody nobody was weightless at
any time never and the way it matters
because you could be standing upside
down in the ship and if it's rotating
all of that works they didn't give any
thought to that especially in the
Guardians of the Galaxy people okay or
what creatures how is it that the cap as
in Captain America can throw his shield
and it comes back to him like a
boomerang because it is a frisbee let's
be honest wait wait I thought it doesn't
just come back to it bounces off of
things back to him it doesn't just come
back like it's on a yo-yo no he throws
it it hits its Target and it comes back
to him otherwise you'd have to run after
it every time he threw it you know what
I I I don't know right so right you're
right so maybe if there's a thing facing
you right there will always be an angle
with which you can throw something where
it bounces straight back to you so he's
just good at pool he's good at he's good
at the at The Cue shot exactly the cue
ball shots bank and stuff right I don't
I never remember seeing it just go just
playing frisbee with himself Yeah okay
or Boomerang with himself right it hits
something and comes back okay okay good
unless I've missed a movie that he was
in where he did that okay next plus it's
very boingy right it's very boingy right
so it'll it'll go and then retain the
energy yes the coil energy and come back
on that one okay next why didn't Ant-Man
go up thanos's butt like you said what
do you mean like I said what do you mean
like I said
Okay that was pretty funny you'll have
to wait for the director's cut Tony
Stark says something like the plank
scale messes with the Deutsch
proposition and creates the epr Paradox
so what the okay what is he talking
about forgive me I don't know what to do
Deutsche proposition is but he did
mention the epr Paradox which is the
Einstein podolsky Rose in Paradox that's
a real thing okay and Einstein is
Einstein the other two are other
physicists and they got together and
explored in the discovery in the dawn of
quantum mechanics it's like this is some
weird stuff is it real right can we
create a thought experiment that is a
paradox that will reveal either a new
truth or Unravel the truth that we think
we've just discovered so I don't know if
there's a Deutsche proposal I think they
just threw that in there if it is I
don't know it okay but epr is a very
well-known Paradox so the epr Paradox is
real well no so Einstein podolsky Rosen
Paradox they just back in the early days
of quantum physics where we're really
scratching our heads no we I wasn't
there but
my people my physics right you know
progenitors here scratching their heads
what does it mean to not be able to
fully know the reality of an object of a
particle Heisenberg noted you can't
simultaneously know the momentum of a
particle or its position precisely at at
the same time so Einstein's uncertainty
principle means you can't know with
accuracy the position of a particle and
its momentum which means its velocity in
which which different speed and
direction it's going okay you can't know
both simultaneously the more you know of
one the less you know of the other ah if
you know the velocity of something you
don't know where it is right if you know
where it is then you know exactly how
fast it's going okay even though you
don't know where it is right
next time you stop for a speeding ticket
right and the cop says do you realize
you've been going 65 miles an hour yeah
but I don't know where I am
and if the cop is quantum physics
literate I bet they let you go yeah
that's gonna happen
experiments to explore the nature of
that reality okay and it was confronting
all of the thinkers of the day to
sharpen their ideas about what quantum
physics is and what it could mean so at
least they may attempt to put some real
science yeah it was intense it was an
attempt okay
third one that's it we got through all
the questions oh my gosh oh wait there's
one more one more go it says Neil I am
Groot
that's the question oh that is a
question that's the question okay so I
think most people in life never really
know who they are so that really at the
end of the day we should be deeply
respectful of Groot who does right
because he knows that
is a cosmic perspective
[Music]